Farscape deserves a
continuation we deserve a continuation
of Farscape welcome to SRA your SciFi TV
and Movie
[Music]
Channel right Farscape is one of those
shows
that I don't know it broke all the rules
it was
seriously ahead of its time and in a
video just over a week ago I spoke to
you about how there are plans for a
Farscape
continuation for once not a reboot not a
reimagining not a remake a continuation
of a great Sci-Fi series that left our
screens well over two decades ago first
of all let me just tell you about my
opinion of Farscape and why personally I
love the show before I talk about why I
think it's show that should come back
and why it would fit on a certain
streaming platform very very well in my
opinion well when I first saw
Farscape I actually sat down and watched
it because of Brian Hensen Productions
because I know this is going to sound
weird but I'm a massive Muppet
[Music]
fan oh what's that a bell time for
school in my childhood was He-Man the
mopets and Thunderbirds that that's
basically was my childhood Thundercats
Thundercats as well a little bit might
have been in love with chitara but when
I first saw Farscape I have to admit I
sat there and went why are they remaking
book roders in the 25th Century another
show that I absolutely loved if you
actually look though at the of book
Rogers and the start of
Farscape they're a bit similar out of
their trajectory into an orbit which
freezes his life support systems and
returns Buck Rogers to Earth 500 years
later my name is John kryon an astronaut
a radiation wave hit and I got shot
through a wormhole now I'm lost in some
distant part of the Universe on a ship a
living ship but actually once you get
past the plot device that was used to
get kryon across the universe and aboard
MOA the Leviathan transport vessel that
centered so importantly in the heart of
this show then there is actually nothing
remotely similar between these two shows
book Rogers and Farscape don't forget
that if you're enjoying the video and
you want to help support the channel we
need you a thumbs up on the video and we
need you to throw a comment on it really
helps with those tricky little YouTube
algorithms Farscape was recently
described as sci-fi crack back by Ben
Browder in an interview he was talking
about the difference between sg1 that he
appeared in the last couple of seasons
of and Farscape and he was saying
basically look they're both sci-fi
they're both amazing but Farscape was
just a little bit more and that SciFi on
crack comment joke it was a joke does
kind of ring true because there was
really a show that had almost no rules
to it it basically just did what it
wanted it was insanely colorful it was a
show that just was completely out there
it kind of knew it didn't have the
budget and it didn't have the fan base
that Star Trek had so it knew it had to
go out there it had to be high concept
sci-fi it had to be high action it had
to be sexy it had to be colorful it had
to be exciting and my God was it it the
writing was not always amazing I won't
lie some of the dialogue was clunky and
a little awkward some of the acting
was let's say interesting and yes okay
the budget was not significant there was
some you know like dodgy special effects
there were some dodgy sets there were
some dodgy storylines but to be honest
all of that just added to the feel of
the show because it wasn't a big budget
Star Trek clean crisp show it was
supposed to be a show about a bunch of
Scoundrels on a living ship fighting
Against All Odds trying to figure out
their way through the universe and that
kind of fit the feel and the tone of the
show in the fact that it was relatively
low budget like the crew of MOA
themselves I personally love Diago now I
know he's dead but when the Show returns
I am going to miss him he was a big
bearded demon of a character he was
bigger than life it was absolutely fun
you know he reminds me of Brian blessed
Gordon's alive and I'm not going to deny
it Claudia Black was seriously sexy in
this and so was XI Edgley as Shana so
Farscape deserves a continuation because
it is that Plucky Underdog a little bit
like
5 I would love to see it return because
it deserves it a show like Farscape
deserves a continuation because it was
Brave it did put itself out there it did
push the boundaries far more than safe
Star Trek ever did so yeah it deserves a
continuation because it was the Plucky
Underdog but also we deserve a
continuation because let's be honest a
lot of sci-fi nowadays is is quite
sanitized it isn't as imaginative it
used to be it's not as high concept as
it used to be even shows like the
foundation which I adore and it is quite
High concept is also is a little bit
sanitized is a little bit
safe and I want to see a show that
actually has The Bravery of Farscape
that doesn't have the expectations or
the demands put on it like a show like
Star Trek does that actually may be
nobody will be watching from the higher
ups they will have a budget that will
allow it just to crack on with it and
then maybe we'll get a Sci-Fi show
that's brave enough to push the
boundaries once again and to be sci-fi
on crack once again I actually think we
deserve that and this show could deliver
it so that is why I think Farscape
deserves a continuation but what do you
think
please get into the comments and tell me
is this a show that you desperately want
to return and if so why do you agree
with me that it pushed the boundaries do
you agree with me that this was a
colorful sexy exciting show that you
know maybe the fact that I had a smaller
budget was not necessarily A Bad Thing
and also where would you put this show
if you got the opportunity I hear that
Amazon is very interested and I'm
wondering if freee might be the perfect
place for this to go somewhere where we
can all see it even though we would have
to put up with the annoying
adverts never mind eh but sidet trackers
what you think is what matters so get
into the comments and tell me if you are
new to the Channel please like subscribe
hit that Bell notification it really
helps us out and you'll never miss any
of our new videos also you can go to
patreon.com sidre where most of our new
videos Premiere first and you get to see
them without the adverts you lucky
bunnies also go to
s.co which is dedicated website where we
do articles based on most of our videos
and we try to add a little bit more
information for you to digest so go and
check it out as always please stay safe
and I'll see you next
[Music]
time